another question for you is regarding a
person who has a wet dream during the
day whilst he's fasting is this an act
which would nullify the fast is it
permitted for a person to have a wet
dream during the day while she's fasting
if a person has a wed dream during the
day while having a fast maybe offers F
Salah and he sleeps and he has a wet
dream it is involuntary a person has a
we dream even if he ejaculates it's
involuntary he's not to be blamed for
that so in this case because it's
unintentional surely it will not break
the fast and he can complete the Fast
and the thing that is advised to him is
that he should have a g a bath as soon
as possible so that he can offer the
Salah that's excellent I think that's
self-explanatory thank you for that